[Música]
aquí comienza a ellos hoy de france24
nuestro programa de hoy es un
reconocimiento a las miles de mujeres
ucranianas que se encuentran atrapadas
en la guerra de rusia en su país con
pocas opciones y su nación en llamas
muchas decidieron huir con sus hijos
hacia las fronteras europeas otras se
quedaron para unirse al ejército
voluntario que defiende el territorio de
los invasores y otras tantas decidieron
regresar del extranjero a luchar ningún
camino está exento de peligros mortales
nuestras corresponsales irene sabio y
leticia álvarez entrevistaron a algunas
de estas mujeres madres de niños
pequeños desplazadas y ciudadanas que
han decidido no escapar y resistir
julia es una ucraniana de madre rusa que
vive en el vive con su marido y sus dos
hijos no quiere dejar el país sigue
trabajando online y se resguardan el
vestíbulo cada vez que las sirenas
retumban en la noche quieren ver nadie
aquí en el vip por ahora estamos a salvo
no hay bombas que caigan del cielo cae
but pero en el resto del país hay
personas que sufren que mueren este es
terrorífico tipo
para juliá lo importante es proteger a
su familia por ello hace un reclamo a
las madres y esposas de los soldados
rusos a
4.739 mantense
a las mujeres rusas les quiero decir
vengan aquí a kiev a hardcore iniciar y
llévense a sus hijos y maridos no se
queden calladas sus hijas no se queden
mirando sentadas mientras nos matan con
dos sets en watch house de a helen as el
en audio de kiev con su esposo y su hija
pero aún vive en vilo pensando que el
bombardeo arrebate la vida a sus
familiares apenas descansa y vive
pendiente de las noticias lo primero que
hago por las mañanas es que llamo
a todos mis parientes
dónde están si están
vimos si están
si tienen
un sitio para
para estar
lo más difícil es explicarle todo a su
hija de 6 años
y no los enseñamos las noticias claro
porque en las noticias se muestran todas
esas pesadillas toda la gente todas esas
casas que están en ruinas juliá daniluk
por ahora se siente segura pero no sabe
hasta cuándo
me preocupa mi hija mi familia y siento
que no tengo cómo proteger los widgets
elena juliá y lina son mujeres que nunca
imaginaron enfrentar una guerra cada una
con su experiencia intenta sobrellevar
con resistencia y estoicismo este cruel
conflicto está en ellas hoy conectado
desde polonia a na tapias a vargas de
apellido sud aquí aviv antes de su
matrimonio con un colombiano anna es una
de miles de mujeres ucranianas que
huyeron cuando inició la invasión y
también está en este programa irene
sabio nuestra corresponsal en ucrania
que se tomó un momento de una ardua y
además valiente cobertura para responder
a nuestras preguntas gracias a ambas por
estar en ellas hoy y para empezar anna
cómo logró salir de ucrania a qué se
dedicaba antes de irse y cómo ha
cambiado su vida desde la huída
buenas tardes soy controladores del
tráfico aéreo en el puerto bories pil y
cuando todo empezó nosotros encontramos
en la ciudad leópolis que queda en huevo
en obras de polonia
entonces pues primera idea de escuchar
las noticias de guerra y de oír todo de
escuchar todo lo que pasaba en la ciudad
nosotros pensamos primero salir a una
familiar que pues era como ahí cerquita
de nuestra ciudad pero ahí mismo en el
camino nos cambiamos la opinión y
decidimos bueno pues intentaremos con
los pocos documentos y cosas que
teníamos intentaremos como irnos a
polonia y si logramos hacerlo con mucha
dificultad pero sí si logramos hacerlo
pues que bueno y bueno quisiera contarle
o pedirle más bien que me cuente qué fue
lo que vio en el camino cuál es la
situación física y emocional de las
mujeres incluyendo la usted que lograron
escapar nosotros sabemos que yo soy
además ha estado intentando ayudar a las
mujeres que llegan a polonia todos los
días
sí pues allá cuando ya cruzamos la
frontera ahí no entendimos que sólo
dejan cruzar a las mujeres con los niños
que a los hombres no les dejan cruzar y
claro que eso eso genera como un momento
súper difícil para las mujeres que que
ellos no saben qué esperar en esos
países nuevos y muchas no tienen ni
fermente ni familiar ni nadie si muchas
no hablan idiomas y entonces es muy
difícil para ellas y pues ahora mientras
mientras ya que nosotros nos como
estamos aquí con mi esposo nosotros
tratamos un poquito también ser como
éste como como es esa esa gente que
puede por lo menos sé hablar inglés y
que pueda conectar algunas que hablan
ucraniano y con la gente que les pueda
ayudar aquí que hablan polaco que quizás
hablo un poco en inglés sí por eso
tratamos después con lo poco que tenemos
pero si intentamos ayudarlos aquí y que
con seguridad es muy valioso en estos
momentos ahora quisiera por favor es
saludable también a irene un gusto
saludarla nuevo
y cuéntenos irene lo mismo que es lo que
usted ha visto en medio de este
desplazamiento masivo de mujeres usted
ha estado en ciudades que en este
momento están bajo fuego
si así es lo cierto es que lo que he
visto son mujeres protagonistas porque
son mujeres que este este momento por
las razones que antes mencionaban están
al mando de la familia porque los
hombres se están quedando en ucrania no
pueden salir se tienen que quedar a
luchar porque es lo que se ha
establecido por ley lo que ha
establecido el gobierno ucraniano y por
tanto estas mujeres mujeres de distintas
generaciones están viajando sola he
encontrado también esta mañana a grupos
enteros de mujeres de distintas edades
que se están haciendo cargo de todas es
una familia y también de en algún caso
de hijos de familias amigas o de hijos
de parientes cercanos entonces por una
parte eso por otra parte lo que también
hemos visto son mujeres que han decidido
aunque sean una minoría pero han
decidido
ir al frente oeste
desde alistarse en estas unidades
territoriales de defensa hemos
entrevistado
a mujeres que son parte de estas estas
organizaciones que se movilizan solo en
época de guerra y que están luchando al
lado de todos los de los hombres como
ellos en las mismas condiciones en las
que están luchando de ellos entonces
realmente yo creo que es posible que en
ucrania se pueda hacer un discurso sobre
todavía una falta de representación
quizás política completa pero en este
momento en esta guerra yo francamente
las ucranianas también pensando en otros
en otros años en los que estado aquí en
este momento yo las veo realmente como
protagonistas de lo que está ocurriendo
y
protagonistas que son conscientes de la
situación y que están luchando cada una
a su manera para
a dar su aporte su contribución
irene pero además es que la guerra en
ucrania no es un paisaje nuevo para las
ucranianas desde 2014 con la caída de
víctor yanukóvich el país ha estado
conmocionado en un conflicto interno con
el don y es con los hanks que con él
después de la anexión de crimea hacia
rusia usted diría que las mujeres ya
están acostumbradas a estar en pie de
lucha porque en cualquier momento podía
agravarse la situación como como ya ha
sucedido porque pues claro
llama mucho la atención que sean las
mujeres las que hayan engrosado las
fuerzas del ejército o de estos
voluntarios que decidieron unirse para
defender su país
si antes me refería precisamente a la
guerra
2014 personal 14 es una guerra que cubrí
pero diría que no porque en realidad fue
una guerra muy circo estricta entonces
este primero tuvimos en el 2014
la ocupación de crimea que realmente
afectó a nivel geográfico sólo esa área
y luego casi inmediatamente después sólo
las zonas de las regiones de lugansk y
dones que y también en este caso
las mujeres si se involucraron pero se
involucraron más en él
como un voluntariado
por ejemplo en quien recuerdo que en
esos años había muchísimas mujeres
integrándose de los desplazados que
también hubo en ese momento personas que
decidieron dejar abandonar crimea o
también las zonas de lugar esquilones
que entonces sí pero no hay de ésta o
sea no era una situación de esta
magnitud no involucra no involucró a
todo el país por ejemplo la zona donde
nosotros nos encontramos en living si
hubo iniciativas pero pero no no no
tiene el mismo tamaño no tiene alguna
proporción que ahora donde realmente hay
la gente viviría que también este caso
los hombres y muchos jóvenes se han
involucrado en masa a ayudar como pueden
los que lógicamente han decidido
quedarse en ucrania pues por supuesto
que si irene más que comprensible y anna
quisiera hablarles sobre otro tema y es
el paradero de la primera dama del país
y los dos hijos de la pareja
presidencial de con volodymyr selenski
ese paradero es reservado por seguridad
sin embargo ella se ha mantenido muy
activa en sus redes sociales y ha
contado de su trabajo
hacer gestiones para sacar de ucrania a
las poblaciones vulnerables niños
adultos mayores personas en situación de
enfermedad cuán importante es para usted
dan a la figura de la primera dama en
este momento de guerra
pues yo creo que para todos ella es como
un símbolo sí de resistencia
pues es mi opinión personal y como
ustedes saben que su esposo no pues el
apoyo bien grande en el tiempo de
elección pero ahora yo creo que ese
apoyo aumentó tremenda igual de él así
como desde su esposa entonces si la ven
como un líder de cómo quieren quieren
tomar su como un ejemplo si para muchos
entonces si yo creo que cualquier
iniciativa que vienen de ellas y es muy
importante y pues las mujeres y lo
valoran muchísimo
pues bien muchísimas gracias a usted por
su testimonio por estar con nosotros nos
solidarizamos con su situación y con su
valentía por lo que vive en este momento
e irene a usted también gracias la
cobertura ha sido constante en france24
hemos tenido acceso a lugares que de
otra manera no podríamos ver y
realidades que no podríamos conocer se
nos queda por fuera el tema de denuncias
que se han expandido en las redes
sociales sobre supuestas violaciones de
soldados rusos y sobre supuestos
proxenetas que buscarían a las
refugiadas para la explotación sexual
información que de momento no se conoce
no ha sido corroborada así que bueno
pues la tarea en ellas hoy para usted
irene y por supuesto usted anna desde la
seguridad de su casa es mantenernos
informadas y ver de qué manera podemos
aportar gracias a ustedes por estar con
nosotros y a nuestros televidentes nos
vemos próximamente en ella surge
[Música]